hello everyone and welcome to a new
tournament that is happening online at
the moment it is the nation's Cup and it
is six nations battling it out to see
who will reign supreme basically the six
nations are united states russia india
china we have Europe and the rest of the
world we're gonna get into details who's
who's playing for who after we check out
the game and we're gonna check out some
standings as yesterday two rounds were
played I don't know how many games I'm
gonna be able to cover from the event
but when our game is as interesting as
this one we are definitely going to
cover it so it's a game from round one
United States vs India
Fabiana Carano vs. we did with trotty
and it's it is quite the game so without
further ado let's let's check it out
yeah so Fabi with the white pieces opens
with E 4 we have e5 Knight to f3 Knight
to c6 and Bishop to b5 going for the
rule opus in 96 everything goes for for
the Berlin defense we have D 3 by Fabi
and Bishop the c5 so this is all all
very standard stuff we have Bishop to a4
castles by black and castles by white
with these six and now c3 making room
for for the lights for Bishop with
Knight to e7 shifting the night over to
g6 and rook to e1 with Knight to g6 and
now Knight B to d2 white also wants to
transfer the night over to g3 and there
is one game in the database that reached
this position where Bishop to g4 was
played it was the game Wesley so versus
Sergey Kerrigan from the riga grand prix
in 2019 that ended in a draw but here we
have c6 by villa and it is a new move so
already as a remove 10 we have a
completely new game c6 preparing the the
early d5 so Fabi continues the Knights
to f1 he's shifting the night over to g3
and a like I said the immediate d5 and
okay Fabi captures and now Knight
captures on d5 if you want to capture
with the C pawn and sort of create a
very strong center white will still ruin
it by playing B force you don't really
get a get a strong central you're just
gonna get an isolated deep on which
White will be able to play against in
the future
so instead Knight captures an b5 by
vidit and now Knight to g4
we have rook to e8 in the now h3 we have
Bishop back to b6 and the white goes
back with the bishop as well the ship
the c2 and now h6 black also wants to
shift the bishop over to c7 we have
Bishop to b2 and now comes Bishop the c7
as planned we have d4 now
white strikes in the center and eat a
person B 4 we have a trade of rooks rook
captures Queen captures in now nightcap
force on d4 and here at Bishop to d7 and
if you look at the position the position
is almost completely identical all of
the pawns are on are on a super
symmetrical squares as you can see in
the Knights also these Knights also the
bishops also as you can see everything
is perfectly symmetrical except the
Queen as you can see if this Queen was
here then we'd have a completely
symmetrical position so it's fair to say
that the position is around equal so far
because a queen to f3 develops the queen
prepares to bring the other rook into
the game and the Queen to e5 with it
centralizes the Queen now wants to shift
the Queen over to d6
and also if this Knight ever moves you
can just infiltrate with Queen to h2 so
rook e1 Bobby kicks the Queen way we
have Queen to b6 and now King to f1 not
allowing any future Knight jumps to come
to come with checks if that happens and
also the King will add additional
protection to the rook and also if
everything else trades off on the board
your king will be one step closer to
improving the position of the King so 95
attacking 5 is queen we have Queen back
to e2 end only now rook to e8 so of
course you do not want your Queen on the
same file as the rook but first Knight
d2 f5 challenging with its Queen we have
Queen back to f8 and only now Queen to
h5 getting the Queen out of the way and
here we have this extremely complicated
position where where it has to has to
decide what to do as you can see both
players have have an almost fully
operational bishop pair so it's not not
very common to see this and you have to
you have to check is this a threat is
this a threat is this a threat what
threats are there
so here we decided to remove one of the
attackers by playing Bishop captures on
f5 but the downside is that he loses the
bishop pair the the absolute best here
there are a couple of good
recommendations but Knight the c-4 seems
to be the way to go
however here you have to really
calculate everything if Bishop captures
on h6 then what happens of course you
cannot capture because then just Knight
captures and you're getting destroyed
King here Knight a5 check captures
captures and and you're just you're just
getting destroyed Queen h4 check King g6
you can trade here captures captures and
let's say Queen Queen to h6 is checkmate
but you have to find that after Knight
to c4 in this capture you can actually
go rook captures anyone but it requires
a lot of calculation King captures here
now go Queen e8 check King goes back now
you capture on g3
sorry after the King moves you capture
on g3 and now if you if you allow pawn
captures then you allow the Knights to
jump to III so you can have to pick it
up with the knight or you don't you
could even just go while sorry about
that the interface kind of kind of went
silly instead you could go just instead
of capturing the bishop you could go
just knife captures on g7 and then it's
who could calculate this position from
that position where you have to decide
what to do here if you found a queen e5
then it's okay and you will you will
probably have a good game but this is
complete madness even though the engine
gives here a 0 0 in the actual over the
board chess no one no one would really
assess this as as an equal position so
instead instead of going into all of
this madness with it eliminates one of
the attackers with Bishop captures on f5
and now we have some trades we have
Knight captures on f5 and Knight to g6
now adding another defender here also
offering a rook trade so we have rook
out force Queen captures in the now g3
by Fabi not allowing any Knight jumps
also numbing the bishop here on c7 and
Knight to f6 by veted pushing back the
Queen we have Queen to f3 and now Queen
to d8 putting pressure on the bishop but
also just preparing Queen to d5 to offer
a queen trade so
the Shabak the c1 and the Queen to d5
offering a queen trade which Fabi
accepts he has the two bishops and he is
he's down to play the same game so Queen
captures Knight captures and now both
players start improving the position of
their King King e2 with King to f8 we
have h4 by Fabi preparing also h5 to
grab more space on the Kings side and
Knight to e5 now we have Bishop to b3
and now Knight to e7 offering a trade of
Knights which Fabi happily accepts
characters captures and now h5 grabbing
more space on the Kings side we have
Knight to d7 buy with it and now Bishop
to d1 so he switches the night over to
f6 as the h5 point is now under attack
but now King d3 the bishop does a nice
job defending it we have be special b6
going after the F do pawn and now F 4
and the g6 now Fabi trades we have
captures captures and now King back to e
2
now the king is coming to f3 we have
Knight to d5 and now King to f3 with h5
by vidit and now Bishop to d2 so slowly
but surely if I be making sure that his
bishop pair is covering pretty much all
of the squares the knight can use end
and then he only then will he start
expanding on the Queen side so King to
have 6 and see for now so it is it is an
equal ish in game but as the players on
both sides of the board and fabulous
have the bishop pair white is white is
to be preferred with nice to e7 and now
Bishop the c3 with check King e6 and now
B for grabbing more space on the Queen
side we have Knight to f5 and now c5
cutting off the dark square Bishop
Bishop the c7 and only now Bishop to b3
with check so you can see that the
bishop pair is doing quite a lot of
damage here King to e7 and now Bishop to
c4 just grabbing more space we have b6
challenging this structure and then now
a for Fabi of course doesn't want to
allow was something like captures and
then give the Knight to d6 square he
wants the opponent to remain and c5 so b
captures and now be captures on c5 so
with it ruined the Fabrice pawn
structure on the Queen side but Fabi
still
controls the the d6 square so King e8
and now even a five we have the ship to
d8 and now Bishop to d3 so Bishop to e7
putting pressure on the c5 pawn and push
it back to be four with Bishop to f6 in
the now comes even a six so you have to
be careful so you don't run into
something like eliminating this pawn but
this this Bishop here is pretty much
stuck guarding the c5 pawn black will
immediately go after it if Y decides to
go for example to go after the a seven
point so Bishop to e7
if it it doesn't allow the Bishop to
move and now Fabi finds a breakthrough
in the King's on the kingside g4 with H
capture screen captures in now 93 check
we have King to f3 and not Knight back
to d5 Knight back to f5 seems also like
a reasonable option just not allowing
any any ideas - why
but wait it goes for an active plan he
goes for Knight to d5 which involves the
temporary pawn sacrifice but he will win
it back so he gives it up with Czech
Bishop character son g6 with check King
f8 in the now Bishop to a3 as the bishop
was under attack we have night the c7
going after the pawn here Bishop to d3
Fabi defends it and not nice to e6 with
a double attack on the c5 bone so this
is how he wins the pawn back Bishop to
c4 and now just Knight captures on c5 so
far B now has a past F pawn whereas with
it has a past C pawn bushra back to c1
and now Knight to d7
we have Quinta efore Fabi starts
improving the position of the King and
as you can see fabi's King is much more
active than then with its king with
Bishop to c5 cutting off the white king
and the King to f5 now we have King to
e7 and now Bishop to b2 controlling the
f6 square we have Bishop to e3 not
allowing the King to go any further as
you're gonna blunder the pawn and now
Bishop to e2 shifting the bishop or over
to this diagonal we have night the b6
and now Bishop to f3 forces the pawn to
move we have c5 and now Bishop the f6
width check King to f7 and now Bishop to
h5 with check we have King to f8 and now
Bishop to e5 defending the pawn so now
the King can move and you can start
pushing your pawn over it also starts
pushing his past pawn we have c4 and
King to e4 now now for the moment
attacking the bishop the ship to c5 and
only now f5 we have Knight to d7
attacking the bishop here and Bishop the
c3 nice square for the Bishop blocking
the passport with Bishop to e7 now
keeping an eye on the f6 square with
both the bishop and the night and here
Bishop back to e to going after this
pawn and night the c5 check now not
defending the pawn but rather going
after the a6 pawn so far B says okay we
have King to e5 and now Knight captures
on a6
bishop characters on nassif on c4 and
now even these two pawns get traded off
and now it's Fabi with the F pawn and
visit with the past a pawn so Knight
back to c5 and here
bishop the back to d2 shifting the
bishop / / - to the Kings side we have
Knight to d7 with check came to e6 and
night to c5 with check fee if it doesn't
allow the King to remain there
King the d5 now by Fabi attacking the
knight and the King to g7 still keeping
control on the f6 square not allowing
Bishop h6
with the shift back to e to end now King
to f6 I think making is very happy there
with Bishop to g4 defending the pawn and
now Knight to d7 we have a bishop the c3
check King to g5 now you have to go to
h3 to both save your bishop and the df5
pawn and brush up to f6 now offers the
trade of course Fabi declines in the
shop today to check King h4 and now you
have to move the bishop bishop to f1 and
Bishop to g5 now again offering a trade
here which Fabi of course declines in
Bishop back to b4 and Knight to f6 width
check with King to e6 and now Knight to
e4 and here Fabi plays a Bishop to d3
and we reach a sort of a critical moment
of the game were vetted played the night
the g3 here he played knife to g3 and he
allowed this point to start marching
forward point is you have to go Knight
f6 but it's also it's also not clear how
how are you going to play play this game
because you could run into trouble
example after Bishop to e2 and this
check here but it's well it's very
complicated for example if King g3 are
gonna go here Bishop the e1 with check
and now you have to go back if you go
here then just Bishop d2 check picks up
the bishop so you have to go to the H
file and then again bishop the c3 goes
after the night but now you have to go
Knights the e4 attack this Bishop here
and the point is now you don't have time
for f6 because why a black can just
capture and after f7 you still defend
the queening square with Bishop to h6 so
it does seem like Knight to f6 what was
the way to go but we did win for night
to g3 and he decided to try and hold
this being being down a piece so far we
pushed f6 and of course you cannot
prevent queening as the bishop also
coverage the f8 squares of the show page
6 it doesn't doesn't really help you so
here we did just gave up the bishop so
King captures and now King to g4 so of
course we know that two bishops against
the King are winning how about two
bishops against the King and night so
let's see how far he goes about this
King g5 and now King to f3
we have Bishop to a6 blocking walking
off that passed pawn so now you can even
just win it with C Bishop c5 captures an
a7
we have Knights to a tube of course you
can never a trade if you ever trade is
just a draw between sufficient material
so rush up to D do not allowing the King
any additional square snide back to g3
and Bishop back to g5 we have Knight to
e4 attacking the bishop and now Bishop
to b7 seemingly winning a piece but not
really because of it it has King G for
now he wants the trade which of course
you cannot allow pleasure back to e3 and
now Knight to g3
we have Bishop to F 2 and now a5 but it
starts to pushing the past pawn but of
course that point we'll never reach any
destinations you you will just capture
it so Bishop the c6 and here if it it
just gives it up with a 4 with Bishop
captures on e4 and now King f3 going
after the bishop and Bishop to d4 so now
you need to create walls against the
White King and the night and really push
them into a corner so King g4 and now
subsidy one with check we have King to
g5 and Bishop to e3 with check King g6
and the now Bishop back to c2 with check
with King to f7 and now Bishop back to
d1 so not not allowing the night any
jumps you're controlling a lot of
squares here which the knight can use to
jump around soaking back to g6 and now
just King g6 with Knight to h5 and now
Bishop the c2 check so you can see all
of these squares are taken from the
black King you can only use these
squares sorry
like that so King g7 and now kink the e7
Knight back to g3 and now Bishop to d3
just controlling all of the squares the
knight can use to jump around so the
knight has to go back and then out brush
up the g5 taking away the f6 square from
the night as well so Knight back to g3
King e6 again the Knight has no good
squares the knight back to h5 for King
f5 now and now of course if you go an IG
3 check then the King just goes here and
you were you're gonna lose that night so
King to f7 and now Bishop the c4 with
check we have king to g7 and now Bishop
the age for not allowing the night to
jump to g3 so King to h6 defending it
and now Bishop to f7 again if the King
moves you just you just lose the night
so Knights the g7 width track and now
kink the g4 the King doesn't have any
squares you have to go here
so King h7 and now King to g5 again the
Knight has no squares the bishop covers
everything so if you move the knight you
lose King h8 now King to g6 and here you
no longer have any squares for the King
you have to move the knight so here
tonight the e6 was played and of course
you will see what happens next I hope
none of you were considering capturing
the night if you capture the night it's
of course stalemate not not not a lot of
fun in that since you already played
such a wonderful game so here after this
night the e6 move Fabi just played
Bishop to f6 check we have Knight goes
back and then just not Bishop captures
and g7 and we have the double Bishop
checkmate so really really an exciting
game and it was really an important game
since USA lost on board for
and then Bobby really needed a win for
USA to equalize against India but yes I
don't know how many games that will show
I will show you these are the results
from round one and these are the results
from round two so as you can see in
round one Europe drew against Russia
with the winners being a bloody silver
team yep and young shift of Duda then we
have China won against the rest of the
world with a result of three to one
evanka way EU yongi and - on board for
and also I forgot to mention every board
every team has a woman on board for so
as you can see in Europe and Russia
animals we took drew against Alexander
Goryeo China and for the rest of the
world we have - a one against Maria Musa
choke and then we have India in the
United States you can see that a humppa
canary won her game and Fabi really
needed to win at equalized so India and
India and USA drew the brooder match and
here we have some games from round 2
Russia lost to the United States were
with a three-to-one result the winners
being Nakamura and Caruana against
anypony she entered a miav rest of the
world defeated India with the only win
by Jorge Cory really really well as a
small upset - definitely against
bhaskaran audubon and it's a really
exciting team the rest of the world
there a job of on board one then future
Jorge Cory and Miriam was a joke really
really an exciting team and here we have
Europe against China Europe lost with a
with a result of 1 to 3 with with the
winners being you young G and the Jew
injured and also I think it's
interesting to mention that Kasparov is
the captain of Team Europe so I'm sure
he's not he's not very happy that they
lost and these are the standings from
fides official Twitter a Twitter account
there is there you see China is in the
lead followed by USA with three points
rest of the world with you and then with
one point India Russia in Europe so
those were the standings I do hope you
enjoyed that as well and we will cover
some of the more interesting games
especially if you if you check up one
that's interesting do use hashtag
suggestion so so I notice it so that's
the game really exciting so now
you know that to bishops against the
king is always winning and to bishops
against the King in night is also always
winning so I just just put it in as well
very instructive game by Fabi and also a
very good game by vidit but yeah I would
like to thank Frank combs Thomas
Schreiber Melvin Zhao George Dell and
Samuel Pearlman for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Nations
Cup and whatever else happens in the
chess world but also we are continuing
our Morphy saga and whatever we have
planned so thank you I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day